[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat pour un numéro spécial
de 100% Sénat consacré à la réforme des
retraites les sénateurs ont poursuivi
hier à l'examen de cette réforme et ils
ont adopté une modification importante
la création d'un CDI senior pour inciter
les entreprises à embaucher des salariés
de plus de 60 ans Alors ce CDI senior
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est un contrat de
travail avec une exonération de
cotisation familiale pour l'employeur
qui pourra mettre un terme à ce contrat
au moment où le salarié atteint l'âge
pour à liquider sa retraite à taux plein
je vous laisse écouter les débats sur ce
CDI senior et sur les moyens que nous
devons y consacrer et pour cela
vous êtes prêts malgré cela vous êtes
prêts supprimer pour le contrat dernier
embauche une part des cotisations à
location familiales qui pèse aujourd'hui
sur les employeurs donc je vous appelle
simplement par cet amendement avec mes
collègues à être cohérent entre d'une
part votre vision de la politique
familiale et d'autre part votre vision
des moyens de croître l'emploi des
seniors merci alors 20h nous allons
demander l'avis de la commission sur
l'ensemble des sous amendements
c'est le rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le Président j'ai
deux minutes par sous amendement je suis
pas obligé de les utiliser rassurez-vous
monsieur le Président mais ça nécessite
quand même des précisions un nous avons
pas parlé du coup pas d'histoire
d'argent monsieur le ministre entre nous
cependant il y a des répercussions
effectivement et vous avez annoncé à ce
titre là un coup de 800 millions d'euros
qu'aurait ce contrat là parce que vous
pensez que il y aura un effet d'aubaine
et que les employeurs vont pas discerner
la différence entre le CDI classique et
le CDI senior qui est différent alors
effectivement on arrive et je confirme
je confirme c'est c'est 800 millions
d'euros mais je pense que le CDI senior
c'est autre chose et s'il y a des
exonérations on peut les estimer plus on
les estime ses exonérations de façon
importante plus plus le bénéfice est
important pour l'ensemble de la société
car si on fait des exonérations à un
coup de prohibitif ça veut dire que
derrière
les cotisations familiales s'entre 30 et
5 entre 3 et 5% sur 40% de cotisations
salariale et patronales donc si vous
perdez pour le budget de l'État ou de la
sécurité sociale 3 à 5 % et que vous
gagnez 40 - 3 5 35 à 37 %, c'est tout
bénef et pendant que votre Seigneur est
employé dans un cadre particulier de ce
CDI senior avec un accompagnement et
bien il n'est pas au chômage et le
chômage on sait que ça coûte cher donc
l'intérêt pour la société pour les
contes de l'État pour les contes de la
sécurité sociale c'est que ce dispositif
enfin marche parce qu'on en a déjà
essayé beaucoup et ça n'a pas toujours
marché il n'empêche que si nous avons
une vision différente contre l'emploi
des seniors il faut se douter d'outils
nouveaux donc je lance effectivement
cette piste là et c'est les partenaires
sociaux qui vont définir par branche
quels sont les branches intéressées si
des branches ne sont pas intéressées et
bien il y a pas de voilà si des branches
sont intéressées et bien elle
définissent qu'elle doit être les
conditions de négociation entre le
salariale employeur quant à cet
accompagnement jusqu'à l'âge légal et
c'est comme les contrats chantiers quand
vous construisez un collège et il y a
des présidents de départements qui sont
là quand vous le construisez un collège
ça dure entre 3 5 7 ans parfois plus et
en conséquence quand vous embauchez des
personnes vous prenez un CDI chantier de
la durée du chantier là c'est la durée
de la fin de carrière merci monsieur le
Président mais je tenais à présenter ces
précisions maintenant je réponds sous
amendements parce que c'est tout à fait
important
madame Lubin propose
d'appeler ça contrat de dernier embauche
je crois qu'on aille mis un avis
défavorable à la commission mais
franchement si ça peut nous réunir qu'on
appelle contrat senior ou dernier
embauche ça correspond à ça ça peut être
l'intitulé de dernier embauche donc là
aussi les partenaires sociaux définiront
la façon dont ils veulent l'appeler
franchement j'ai aucun état d'âme
là-dessus mais ça rejoint notre
préoccupation parce que c'est celle que
nous avions définies lors lors du
rapport que nous avions fait sur
l'emploi des seniors donc c'est tout à
fait important en ce qui concerne
Olivier nos Olivier Hainaut nous propose
effectivement de déterminer un âge
différent alors déjà monsieur le
ministre des comptes sociaux et des
comptes de l'État nous disent que ça
coûte cher à 60 ans Alors j'ai pas osé
franchement
envisagé qu'on puisse le mettre à partir
de 55 ans bien entendu ce sont des
partenaires sociaux qui selon les
branches nous dirons quel âge il faut
mettre voyez ça n'a justement c'est pas
d'ici de niveau du Parlement qu'on va
définir tout cela on a véritablement une
négociation qui peut s'instaurer par
branche et peut-être que on peut
comprendre que c'est un âge différent
selon le type de métier à mesure la
pénibilité on aura l'occasion de le
définir c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai mis un avis défavorable en ce qui
concerne effectivement
je crois que c'est
je ne sais plus qui excusez-moi non
c'est aussi Monique Monique Lubin
jusque 70 ans oui 70 ans c'est le seuil
c'est toi je crois 70 ans c'est le seuil
actuel
d'emploi où on peut effectivement
définir une rupture
unilatérale demandée par l'employeur
pour mise à la retraite avec des
conditions bien spécifiques en ce qui
concerne les cotisations le forfait
social qui est adapté à ce type de
prestation avant 70 ans si l'employeur
ne souhaite rompre avec son employé sa
dispositif de licenciement classique ou
une rupture conventionnelle
c'est un frein il faut bien reconnaître
aujourd'hui savoir quand vous avez des
seniors qui peuvent rester jusqu'à 70
ans parce que ça dépend du salarié quand
il peut partir à la retraite il prévient
je pars à la retraite sauf que s'il ne
veut pas partir à la traite
effectivement nombre d'entreprises nous
disent on est contraint de par la loi de
les garder jusqu'à 70 ans et en
conséquence en conséquence ça peut poser
un problème quand vous embauchez un
seigneur vers 60 60 ans
ça fera l'emploi et beaucoup
d'entreprises
hésitent parce que
voyez-vous on peut comprendre que donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut un
contrat spécifique incitatif pour rompre
ce frein à l'emploi parce que compte
tenu de la longévité il faut vraiment
qu'il y ait cette prise de conscience et
pour que elle soit véritablement
collective et ben donnons des outils
pour aider à prendre conscience que les
seniors ça va effectivement contenu de
la longévidée peut-être travailler un
peu plus longtemps en tout cas il faut
que ça puisse être ainsi si on veut
éviter de les mettre dans le dispositif
chômage et trop souvent de la précarité
en ce qui concerne les exonérations
pour lequel on a eu deux remarques
particulières oui nous sommes pas fans
des exonérations et mais cependant
cependant cependant
exonération familiale la branche famille
Laurence Rossignol oui
nous voulons et nous allons l'affirmer à
travers la surcotisation que nous
proposerons pour les maires de famille
qui ont une majoration dès l'instant où
elles ont eu l'âge du taux plein avant
un ange légal etc donc cette majoration
nous it non mais c'est la contrainte
d'un PLFSS si je propose moi je vais
proposer à titre personnel une
exonération chômage ça me paraît
tellement logique puisque vous avez un
contrat qui fait que vous engagez de
garder jusqu'à la retraite votre salarié
donc il n'ira pas dans la cage chômage
en conséquence ce serait légitime qui
est une exonération de la cotisation
chômage là aussi c'est les partenaires
sociaux qui vont le dire ou à travers
une loi travail que vous pourrez lui
proposer on ne peut pas dans le cadre du
PLFSS puisque je vous rappelle mais vous
le savez bien vous tous que les contenus
lunédiques ne rentrent pas dans le cas
du pérfss
contrairement à ce que nous
contrairement merci madame la Présidente
contrairement à ce que nous demandions
rappelez-vous nous pensions que nous
pourrions avoir un regard voyez ça nous
est le permis de voir les choses un
petit peu différemment mais les
exonérations mes chers collègues
on peut se les permettre quand on a une
assiette assez importante pour les
cotisations la France ne produit pas
assez c'est bien notre difficulté c'est
pour ça que nous avons une base annonce
commerciale négative il faut élargir la
base de cotisations et cette réforme va
dans ce sens-là et à ce moment-là si
vous avez élargi votre base de
cotisation les exonérations prennent une
dimension tout à fait différente
je pense avoir répondu à toutes les
interrogations qui a été traduite à
travers tous ces amendements merci alors
la vie du gouvernement à la fois sur
l'amendement de Monsieur Savary
au nom de la commission sociale
et puis sur les sous-amendements merci
monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales Monsieur et Madame et Monsieur
les rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs nous sommes venus à deux
avec mon collègue mise et Lego compte
public pour tenter de résister aux Astro
de monsieur le rapporteur et de la
commission des affaires sociales donc si
vous voulez bien monsieur le Président
je répondrai sur les aspects qui
relèvent du code du travail et peut-être
que mon collègue pourra répondre sur le
la partie du coup
concernant ce contrat nous avons à ce
stade trois interrogations deux attentes
et une crainte que je partage avec vous
les trois interrogations quant à la mise
en oeuvre du contrat proposé par la
Commission des affaires sociales
concernent d'une part le principe
d'égalité avec la difficulté lorsqu'on
crée des bornes d'âge sur l'accès à une
contrat de travail d'une nature
spécifique le risque qu'il y ait des
effets de seuil des effets d'aubaine et
des effets de distorsion la deuxième
interrogation concerne le de cet outil
et nous souhaiterions voir s'il est
possible d'aller vers un ciblage en
termes de bénéficiaires concernant
plutôt les demandeurs d'emploi que
l'ensemble des seniors pour éviter
prévenir toute forme d'effet d'auben et
puis évidemment nous souhaitons puisque
j'ai évoqué ce terme d'effet de Ben
veillez à ce que la différence entre le
CDI droit commun et ce nouvel outil qui
pourrait s'adresser au Seigneur soit une
différence particulièrement marquée je
donne bien volontiers actes sur le
rapporteur d'un certain nombre de
discussions de modifications notamment
dans la rédaction de l'amendement pour
envoyer une concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux puisque nous
considérons et c'est là l'occasion pour
moi de venir sur les deux points qui
sont des attentes que le gouvernement
exprime à cette occasion nous
considérons qu'il y aurait d'une part un
intérêt à ce que cette mesure soit créée
de nature avec nature dans un premier
temps expérimental et d'autre part nous
considérons que ce CDI propre senior
relève d'un article que monsieur le
Président du Sénat connais bien
l'article la partie dite L1 du code du
travail et qui cela doit renvoyer à une
concertation interprofessionnelle là où
nous avons encore un écart dans la
rédaction la préparation de ce
dispositif avec monsieur le rapporteur
c'est que le gouvernement considère
qu'il y aurait lieu de renvoyer la
totalité des paramètres et de la
définition du nouveau contrat un décret
faisant suite à une concertation
interprofessionnelle alors que la
rédaction de l'amendement prévoit à ce
stade une écriture plus précise sans
toutefois exonérer le gouvernement d'une
obligation de concertation
interprofessionnelle selon ce sont là
les trois points que je voulais
souligner d'une part des interrogations
d'autre part le fait que nous donnons
bien évidemment acte un monsieur
rapporteur et la commission qu'un
certain nombre de modifications allant
dans le bon sens sont déjà intervenus et
enfin deux points d'attente sur le
caractère expérimental et sur
l'articulation avec le L1 du Code du
travail que je voulais souligner je le
fais monsieur le Président en ayant bien
en tête et monsieur le rapporteur que
lorsque l'article du Code du travail
concernant l'obligation de concertation
interprofessionnelle
a été intégré au code du travail je
crois en 2003 ou 2004 2004 il me semble
sous votre autorité il avait été
explicitement prévu que cette obligation
de concertation interprofessionnelle ne
concernait ni les propositions de loi ni
les amendements mais je crois que
l'esprit et je crois aussi que c'est
partagé que l'esprit prévôt et que il
est utile d'avoir une concertation
interprofessionnelle sur ces sujets là
voilà les remarques qui m'amènent à dire
qu'à à ce stade et en fonction de la
rédaction qui est proposé à cet instant
au Sénat la vie du gouvernement ne peut
pas être favorable et donc par
conséquent il est il est défavorable
mais avec l'espoir que les discussions
et je l'espère les débats que nous
auront encore cette semaine et ensuite
dans la perspective de la prolongation
du débat parlementaire autour de ce
texte nous puissions trouver un terrain
d'entente monsieur le ministre Attal
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs et sénatrice et sénateur moi
je vous remercie de mettre ce sujet là
sur la table puisque je crois qu'on
cherche tous à réduire le chômage chez
les seniors et à ce titre c'est toujours
intéressant évidemment de discuter des
pistes qui sont proposées moi je suis
toujours assez sceptique sur des
propositions d'allègement de cotisation
ciblées sur un âge donné aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas d'allègement de cotisations
liées à un âge il y a des allègements de
cotisations qui sont liés à un type de
contrats qui sont liés à une
rémunération non les jeunes monsieur
Husson on parle d'allègement sur les
jeunes parce que il y a des allègements
qui sont ciblés sur les niveaux de
salaire au SMIC et que c'est
principalement des jeunes qui sont au
SMIC mais vous n'avez pas de vous n'avez
pas d'allaagement de cotisation lié à un
âge pour une bonne raison à mon avis
c'est que le risque c'est qu'il y a des
effets de seuil
si vous dites il y a un allègement de
cotisation pour l'employeur à partir de
60 ans qu'est-ce qui va se passer pour
les gens qui ont 58 59 ans qui se
présentent dans une entreprise pour être
recruté on va leur dire vous ne coûtez
plus cher que ce que vous ne coûterait à
60 ans donc attendez attendez un an ou
deux ans revenez me voir dans un an ou
dans deux ans quand j'aurai droit à une
exonération de cotisation parce que vous
avez plus de 60 ans donc le risque c'est
qu'on décale le problème et que c'est
que des personnes qui aujourd'hui en
plus 60 ans et sont au chômage en fait
on décale le problème à ceux qui sont
juste avant 60 ans parce que eux
n'auront pas droit à l'exonération pour
leur employeur s'ils sont recrutés ça
c'est la première chose sur la deuxième
chose c'est un amendement qui coûte
effectivement
une certaine somme le chiffre de 800
millions d'euros c'est 800 millions
d'euros si les recrutements actuels
au-delà de 60 ans se font avec le CDI
senior on parle des faits d'auben c'est
à dire que aujourd'hui vous avez
aujourd'hui vous avez en moyenne 100 000
CDI qui sont signés pour des personnes
qui ont plus de 60 ans par an
si désormais tous ces CDI signés pour
des personnes qui ont plus de 60 ans
chaque année sont faits avec le nouveau
contrat bah non bah en même temps vous
vous prenez vous mettez à la place d'un
employeur vous dites il y a un nouveau
contrat CDI senior qui existe avec moins
de cotisation il va plutôt choisir
celui-là aujourd'hui vous avez 100000
personnes qui sont recrutées en CDI
après 60 ans si désormais ils sont tous
recrutés avec ce nouveau CDI ça coûte
800 millions d'euros pour la branche
famille et ça veut dire que la branche
famille se retrouve déficitaire dès
l'année 2025 or j'entends sur tous les
bancs une volonté d'avoir une politique
familiale ambitieuse pour notamment
inciter à la natalité dans notre pays je
rejoins cet objectif mais donc là on se
retrouve à dépouiller la branche famille
si on va encore plus loin sur l'effet
d'aubaine ça veut dire si toutes les
personnes qui sont actuellement en
emploi en CDI de plus de 60 ans
l'employeur se dit bah en fait j'ai un
allègement de cotisations qui change de
CDI donc on va toutes les basculer en
CDI senior là ça coûte 2 milliards 300
millions d'euros je dis pas qu'on ira
jusque là monsieur le rapporteur
évidemment
mais en tout cas ça veut dire que si
toutes les personnes qui sont
aujourd'hui en CDI au-delà de 60 ans
elles sont basculées dans un contrat CDI
seniors
ça ferait ça ferait ce coup-là j'entends
que vous souhaitez et notamment dans la
discussion avec les partenaires sociaux
qui est des garde-fous pour qu'ils
puissent pas y avoir tous ces effets
d'aubaine mais en tout cas le fait est
que sur les 100000 recrutement qui a
chaque année après 60 ans s'ils sont
tous recrutés au CDI seniors et encore
une fois vous mettez à la place de
l'employeur il y a une baisse de
cotisation va plutôt le faire deuxième
chose deuxième chose c'est un dispositif
qui va plutôt favoriser les hauts
revenus les hauts salaires ceux pour les
CE pour qui la question des cotisations
n'est pas l'élément déterminant pour les
employeurs si je vous donne quelques
chiffres pour un salarié qui a un une
rémunération de 4500 euros aujourd'hui
vous aurez un effet maximal de baisse de
cotisation alors même que pour un senior
qui a une rémunération autour de 2000
2500 euros il y a déjà des allègements
de cotisation notamment avec le bandeau
famille et donc l'effet incitatif serait
le plus fort pour des salariés qui ont
les plus hautes rémunérations pour
lesquelles a priori l'incitation sur les
cotisations n'est pas l'élément
déterminant pour leur recrutement donc
c'est au moins 800 millions d'euros de
coûts pour des salariés et des seniors
donc a priori il y a pas le son pour
lesquels il y a le plus besoin d'un
effet incitatif sur les cotisations donc
moi encore une fois j'ai l'air sur ce
sujet là il y a des dispositifs un peu
semblables qui ont été testés au niveau
européen et un rapport très intéressant
de France stratégie de 2017 qui dit que
ces dispositifs d'exonération
d'allègement de cotisations ciblées sur
les seniors dans les pays qui l'ont
essayé c'est à dire la Finlande la Suède
et la Hongrie se sont révélés
inefficaces à la fois sur les
recrutements et sur les salaires donc
encore une fois on partage tous le même
objectif moi vous le savez j'ai pas de
tabou sur les allègements de cotisation
les baisses de cotisation je pense que
quand c'est
ça vous le savez non mais vous le savez
donc ça donc ça rend donc ça rend ma
position ça rend ma position d'autant
plus forte et objective moi je pense que
oui oui il y a des exonérations et des
allègements qui sont utiles mais il faut
qu'on soit sûr de leur efficacité en
l'occurrence là je crée un effet
d'aubaine qui mette notre branche
famille dans le rouge donc pour ces
raisons défavorables
merci alors nous allons commencer
mille excuses de rallonger un peu le
débat mais je préfère répondre je répète
je préférerais prendre tout de suite à
monsieur le ministre c'est le ministre
je ne crois pas que vous n'avez pas
compris le dispositif je pense que vous
avez la posture du gardien du temple ce
que je comprends bien du temple
financier je le comprends bien non non
il est pas question que les CDI de 60
ans soient tous pris en compte dans ce
dispositif il est question de proposer
une alternative d'où l'intérêt des
branches de définir dans les branches
l'intérêt de ce CDI non jusqu'à présent
dans les CDI on discute pas d'histoire
d'âge avec avec le salarié tandis que là
ça veut dire que il y a un aspect très
confidentiel jusqu'à présent où le
salarié expose ses conditions de
retraite on regarde sur un faux retraite
les conditions c'est comme un contrat de
chantier donc ça veut dire que par
rapport à ces exonérations de tous les
emplois de 60 ans vous auriez
vous auriez
une embauche supplémentaire de seniors
c'est la raison pour laquelle ça mérite
d'exister alors maintenant vous parlez
d'histoire de bornage pas de bornage moi
je suis mais alors à 100% d'accord avec
vous mais 100% mais pourquoi pourquoi
dans l'article suivant vous nous
proposez des bornages pour les carrières
longues parce qu'effectivement celui qui
a 4 à Sainte trimestre avant la fin de
l'année de l'âge d'un tel mais pas de
peau à chaque fois qu'on a eu des
discussions avec nos collègues ils m'ont
demandé tiens je suis questionné Ah bah
non il a que trois trimestres celui-là
il en a pas 4 à 5 les bordages c'est
terrible c'est la raison pour laquelle
moi on en met mieux c'est mais si on met
pas des bandages dans votre dispositif
monsieur le ministre vous me parlez des
bornes pour le calcul des cotisations
soit les bornes c'est bien soit les
bornes c'est pas bien vous avez mis des
bornes de cotisations différentes
4,5,15 au sud de 3,5 SMIC et puis en
dessous un taux différentiel j'en sais
rien mais déborde effectivement ça
devient incontournable quoi hein donc
soyons attentifs la CSG c'est déborde et
là ça veut dire effectivement vous me
coûtez trop cher donc finalement je vais
vous payer moins cher comme ça j'ai une
cotisation qui est en dessous donc on
voit bien que tout ça pour voir le
dispositif alors soit il y a une volonté
d'accepter le dispositif soit il y a
effectivement il y a la volonté de pas
l'accepter et mes chers collègues je
vous incite plutôt à aller dans le sens
de la Commission de façon à donner
davantage d'espoir au seniors merci
nous allons donc
voter d'abord les sous amendements pour
le bonheur oui oui non non vous pouvez
expliquer votre vote et aucun problème
et je vais et je signale que je suis
saisi du demande de scrutin public sur
l'amendement de la commission présentée
par les rapporteurs le 21/12 qui aura
lieu à la fin de l'examen des sous
amendements pour le bon ordre de nos
débats
alors madame Lubin
merci monsieur le président
moi je ne comprends pas pourquoi on est
toujours obligé de faire des cadeaux aux
entreprises pour que elle recrute des
gens soit c'est des jeunes soit c'est
des seniors soit c'est finalement et
alors les entreprises recrutent qui des
gens qui ont entre 25 et 55 ans et puis
après avant ça va pas après ça va plus
moi j'aurais préféré que l'on me demande
de juste aux entreprises en fonction de
certains critères de recruter ou de
maintenir un emploi des seniors pour
qu'elle puisse garder les diverses
exonérations auxquelles elles ont déjà
droit
on n'aurait pas eu besoin d'en rajouter
on leur demanderait un effort par
rapport à ce à quoi elles ont déjà droit
nous nous avons fait aussi par exemple
une proposition
de d'un recrutement ou enfin ou plutôt
de la présence d'un minimum de 15 % ou
d'un plancher de 15 % de seniors dans
les entreprises
en gérant le flux c'est à dire soit on
ne se débarrasse pas des gens de plus de
55 ans et lorsqu'on a des postes à
pourvoir on ne on ne on ne comment dire
on ne se prive pas des candidatures de
gens de plus de 55 ans ça aurait déjà
été un bon me semble-t-il une bonne
proposition puis la dernière des
remarques elle est générale elle est
d'ordre général le Medef qui a été
auditionné et que nous avions vu aussi
l'occasion d'auditionner avec René Paul
Savary le Medef est particulièrement
favorable à ce projet de report de l'âge
de recul de l'âge de la retraite et dans
le même temps
il y est favorable mais il refuse
catégoriquement de faire des efforts en
matière de recrutement des gens de plus
de 50 ans voilà donc j'ai envie de dire
ça devient un petit peu pénible quand
même et à un moment il faudra bien
trouver un moyen et moi je le propose
c'est au travers des exonérations déjà
existantes et je vais terminer en disant
que j'ai lu dans la presse ce matin que
le gouvernement je vous donne de la TVA
là
ce matin
le tourna les nous
servira le temps il va se passer plein
de choses au printemps moi j'aurais aimé
qu'on pense automne c'est à dire qu'on
nous propose une loi travail avant une
loi retraite monsieur chanterelle et
chacun respecte bien son temps
merci monsieur le Président alors
monsieur le rapporteur Sabari vous aurez
dû renommer votre amendement
l'amendement Medef parce que c'est c'est
une commande directe du Medef cette
mesure va dans le bon sens à déclarer
Eric chevet le vice-président de la CPME
on n'est pas étonné de sa réaction parce
que avec ce CDI senior vous allez
permettre au patron d'être exonéré des
cotisations familles c'est-à-dire 5% du
salaire brut tout de même au passage le
ministre des comptes publics monsieur
Attal qui lui n'est pas là pour faire
une réforme de gauche mais pour serrer
la vis vous êtes à l'armée justement du
coup pour les finances publiques 800
millions d'euros
on se demande bien ce qui va rester des
économies prévues soit disant par la
réforme avec le recul de l'âge de départ
à la retraite mais veut revenons à la
proposition du rapporteur pourquoi donc
des honorations de cotisation famille
quel rapport avec l'emploi des sonneurs
aucun si ce n'est d'en profiter pour
siphonner la branche famille de la
sécurité sociale redevenu excédentaire
en 2021 non en fait c'est parce que
Monsieur Savary n'a pas eu le choix de
son propre aveu dans une entrevue que
vous avez donné à Ouest-France vous avez
dit il aurait été plus judicieux de
proposer une exonération de cotisations
chômage et oui mais la réforme des
retraites passe par un projet de loi
rectificatif de financement de la
sécurité sociale et l'assurance chômage
est en dehors de ce cadre voilà sur la
forme le résumé de toute l'absurdité du
débat que nous sommes en train d'avoir
mais sur le fond avec ce CDI dérégulé et
à bas coût que va-t-il se passer on
risque de mettre en concurrence des
seniors avec les jeunes sur le seul
critère du coup du travail or les jeunes
eux-mêmes ont aussi beaucoup de mal à
s'insérer c'est la raison pour laquelle
monsieur saberet nous voterons contre
votre amendement je suis gay
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues moi je
voudrais d'abord remercier le rapporteur
Savary parce qu'avec cet amendement il
me rappelle ma jeunesse où je me suis
engagé en 2006 contre le contrat
première embauche et nous avions obtenu
le retrait comme nous obtiendrons le
retrait je le sais de cette réforme des
retraites et je trouve l'expression de
notre collègue Lubin très fort à propos
le contrat dernier embauche bon
premièrement
on a d'abord les effets
quand on a reporté l'âge légal de 60 à
62 ans ça a été nul sur l'embauche des
seniors qui n'était pas au travail nul
et donc les 1 million quatre de
personnes qui sont entre 53 et 69 ans
qui sont aujourd'hui sans emploi ni
revenus il y aura pas plus d'embauche
avec ce contrat dernier embauche
premièrement la deuxième l'argument de
du ministral est fort à propos là aussi
c'est qu'on va signer la branche famille
des cotisations sociales et on va la
sécher donc je n'y reviens pas c'est
mieux quand c'est lui qui le dit plutôt
que le groupe communiste dernière chose
les exonérations de cotisations là on va
avoir un point divergent avec évidemment
monsieur le ministre
on a déjà quand même un certain nombre
de choses pour les évaluer par exemple
le cice qui s'est transformé en
exonération de cotisation je lis le
rapport France stratégie le dernier en
date 2020 les résultats restent
conformes aux conclusions des années
précédentes un fort effet emploi est
trouvé chez le quart des entreprises les
plus bénéficiaires du cice qui ne
représentent qu'un huitième des
effectifs mais rien ne significatif chez
les autres l'effet total restait si mais
à 5000 emplois nous en avait promis un
million à l'époque ce qui est faible
rapporté au coût du cice de l'ordre de
18 milliards 18 milliards pour 5000
emplois ça fait 180000 euros pour chaque
emploi qu'on sait que ça a l'air médian
est aux alentours de 33000 euros chargé
donc vous voyez ça ne marchera toujours
pas je vous remercie monsieur le
Président Madame Brulin
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues c'est vrai que ce contrat en
envie de l'appeler dernière embauche
pour les raisons que viennent de
rappeler Monique Lubin et Fabien gay
mais je suis pas davantage d'accord avec
le fait qu'on en dise que c'est un CDI
parce que un contrat dont on connaît
l'âge de début et l'âge de faim ça
ressemble quand même beaucoup plus à un
CDD qui a un CDI
enfin les exonérations effectivement
sur la branche famille vous nous avez
expliqué monsieur le rapporteur que
votre préférence aurait été à des
exonérations chômage tout ça confirme
qu'on est quand même de plus en plus
dans du bricolage autour de cette
réforme et c'est ça n'est pas sans nous
inquiéter et puis ça donne quand même
l'impression que certains ici ne
supportent pas qu'une branche de notre
système de protection sociale soit
excédentaire la branche famille enfin
mes chers collègues on va entendre un
peu différemment tout ce que vous allez
nous dire prochainement sur ce que vous
voulez faire en direction des familles
quand dès que vous avez vu l'occasion
vous diminuez les recettes pour la
branche famille on pourrait dire la même
chose de la branche accident du travail
maladie professionnelle qui elle aussi
est devenue excédentaire et qui à la
faveur de cette réforme va se voir aussi
spolier un certain nombre de ressources
on a bien compris monsieur le ministre
que les exonérations de cotisation
n'étaient pas tabou pour vous c'est même
malheureusement quasiment la seule
solution que vous mettez en avant à
quasiment chaque problème or il y a des
exonérations de cotisations qui se sont
multipliées pour les basses à l'air ce
qui a contribué à tirer les salaires
vers le bas qui des salaires qui sont
plutôt d'ailleurs le fait de début de
carrière et aujourd'hui on en prend
argument pour dire bah il faudrait aussi
des exonérations de cotisations pour les
fins de carrière parce que sinon ils
sont plus concurrentiels avec les débuts
de carrière et puis ensuite on va nous
dire bah écoutez pour tous les autres il
va falloir aussi des exonérations et
c'est comme ça qu'on arrive à la
situation que connaît notre financement
de la protection sociale nous proposons
de prendre le chemin exactement inverse
madame Bocquet
monsieur Bocquet c'est Madame briquet
auquel je pensais non non j'ai aucun
doute on va bien de ce président
les semaines se suivent et de se
ressemblent pas la semaine dernière nous
combattons pieds à pied une aspiration
une réforme d'aspiration libérale votre
choix est depuis hier le monde a changé
nous grâce à la presse nous apprenons
que nous contestons désormais une
réforme de gauche ce matin
je voulais partager avec vous ce
sentiment mes chers collègues sentiment
très étrange pour le groupe communiste
en attendant ce contrat de fin de
carrière censé favoriser l'embauche des
seniors s'appuie sur un seul argument
d'attractivité cela a été dit par mes
collègues l'exonération des cotisations
familiales de l'employeur exonération
que nous combattons parce que elles ont
le fâcheuse inconvénient de créer du
déficit de d'affaiblir les recettes d'un
régime et donc nous combattons pieds à
pied cette cette logique là alors
pensons sérieusement améliorer le taux
d'emploi des seniors qui est je le
rappelle de 56% pour les 55 64 ans en
exonérant les employeurs d'une
cotisation actuellement fixée à
3,45%, soit une économie de 129 euros
sur un salarié payé à 3745 euros vous
pensez résoudre la question des seniors
licenciés à 59 ans en baissant de 60
euros les cotisations des entreprises
sur un salaire médian qui franchement
croira à cette fable
monsieur le Président rénal
oui merci monsieur le Président et bien
comment dire j'ai le plaisir ce matin
d'être d'accord pour la première fois
avec des deux ministres présents et
j'allais dire sur l'ensemble des
arguments me semble-t-il bon
et voyez-vous je crois monsieur le
rapporteur je vous crois de bonne foi je
le dis dans votre recherche d'une
solution mais ensuite la bonne foi
n'excuse pas le fait qu'il faut entendre
des choses qui sont vraies et qui sont
me semble-t-il tout à fait justifiés
bon ben ça ça existe toujours il y a
même un effet domaine qui pourrait être
encore plus plus terrible ça serait de
licencier un an avant et ensuite de
réembaucher selon un nouveau contrat pas
les mêmes personnes mais d'autres
personnes donc si vous voulez on connaît
les pratiques de certaines entreprises
c'est pas tous les chefs d'entreprise
heureusement mais de certains
entreprises qui jouent effectivement sur
les effets d'aubaine et nous les
connaissons
l'exonération famille j'y reviens pas
c'est curieux de proposer l'exonération
de famille mais vous l'avez expliqué
c'était pas votre objectif mais voilà et
puis le renvoi à la négociation
interprofessionnelle c'est du bon sens
c'est du bon sens ou la BD d'ailleurs
vous-même il faut y revenir mais
laissons levenir laissons le venir de la
négociation interprofessionnelle
laissons chercher les solutions au
niveau au niveau des branches je pense
que c'est comme ça bon donc pour moi le
sujet numéro un d'ailleurs c'est pas
celui-là c'est d'abord de conserver les
seniors qui sont au travail avant de
savoir comment on réembauche comment
dans les entreprises on maintient les
gens au travail jusqu'à à l'âge à la fin
de l'âge légal au minimum
donc moi je vous demanderai au vu de ce
qui s'est dit et de ce qui s'est dit de
manière à tout à fait correcte
je vous remercierai monsieur le
rapporteur de considérer que vous avez
fait
œuvre utile que vous avez déposé un
amendement d'appel et que maintenant au
vu de ce qui s'est dit très logiquement
vous le retirez madame ma pour ce poli
merci monsieur le Président alors nous
nous opposons évidemment fermement à cet
amendement des rapporteurs nous avons
déjà bien du mal à trouver je vous le
rappelle de l'emploi et un CDI pour les
jeunes et vous n'avez vous pour ligne de
mire que de tirer sur une rognonbulance
à savoir évidemment exploiter jusqu'à la
dernière force des seigneurs et puis
vous avez certainement reçu évidemment
les félicitations du Medef pour votre
belle amendement parce qu'il le réclame
à corps et à Christ vous nous assumez de
cette réforme est une réforme de justice
sociale pourtant il s'agit bien notre
casser encore plus nos seigneurs avant
même de vous parler du droit au repos ou
comme vous aimez l'appeler ici dans
cette hémicycle le droit à la paresse
nous vous rappelons que le droit
fondamental au respect de la vie privée
familiale que vous torpillez que cela
soit avec la réforme mais également avec
cet
déconnecter complètement déconnecté de
la réalité du travail de la durée de la
dure réalité du labeur des salariés de
ce pays pour bien des travailleurs à
chaque jour suffit sa peine et par cet
amendement vous souhaitez nous vendre
comme de mauvais publicitaires que vous
êtes l'idée selon laquelle nos seniors
n'attendent qu'une seule chose continuer
continuer à travailler mes chers
collègues cet amendement ne parle à
personne si ce n'est qu'au patron vous
vous détachez de la réalité de millions
de Français de celle de millions de
travailleurs précaires pour favoriser
une fois encore les mêmes et vous
envisagez de les choyer de surcroît en
les exonération de cotisations sociales
ne pensez-vous pas qu'il est absolument
contre-productif de recruter des
personnes qui sont usées à des postes
qui nécessitent motivation et à
endurance votre amendement contrevient à
toute forme de pertinence et d'humanité
nous voterons contre merci monsieur
jaumier
merci Monsieur président écoutez ce
dispositif à au moins un mérite c'est
comme il comporte une disposition sur
les cotisations sociales et les
conformes à une LSS ce qui est pas le
cas de tous les articles donc il faut
quand même le noter pour le reste le
rapporteur a fait un lien intéressant
d'ailleurs à souvenir entre la
production et les exonérations de
cotisation moi je veux dire j'ai regardé
les résultats ils sont pas flagrants
franchement depuis que cette politique
est devenue massive notamment depuis
on peut pas dire que la balance
commerciale de la France se soit
vraiment amélioré c'est fortement
dégradé et nos capacités de production
sont pas fortement en hausse c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est un
euphémisme donc la question qui se pose
c'est que ces exonérations de
cotisations surtout elles sont un
phénomène permanent de modification de
la dépense publique dans notre pays
c'est là où ce projet de loi retraite a
aussi un versant qui est intéressant on
transfère toujours plus d'argent vers
des entreprises la dépense publique
c'est une baisse des dépenses en faveur
des services publics et les gens ils le
voient partout autour d'eux c'est pas la
peine de répéter la justice où elle en
est la santé etc
c'est des dépenses vers les ménages et
là on y est au cœur avec la question des
retraites et c'est du transfert vers les
entreprises et quand on passe de 2018 à
2023 de 38 à 73 milliards d'euros les
exonérations de cotisations sociales et
qu'on augmente massivement les transfert
vers les entreprises il faut bien
prendre l'argent quelque part alors on
le prend sur les services publics qui
sont à l'os et quand même partout dans
nos départements c'est la catastrophe et
on le prend maintenant sur le transfert
vers les ménages là on voulant récupérer
de l'argent sur le système de retraite
alors tout ça est un choix politique
très clair mais il faut l'assumer
maintenant il faut l'assumer et je suis
heureux qu'une part oui oui dans votre
camp chez les républicains il y a des
députés qui ouvrent les yeux et qui
disent ça suffit on ne peut plus aller
dans ce sens là monsieur hennaux
oui merci monsieur le Président violé
ministre d'abord une remarque monsieur
chanterelle a dit tout à l'heure que
monsieur le rapporteur répondait à une
commande du Medef je trouve cette
remarque désobligeante déplacée et ça
vous grandit pas voilà et comme vous
êtes coutumier du fait je voulais le
faire ce matin je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr sur cette question sur cette
amendement nous avons un doute sur le
risque d'effet d'aubaines
nous avons naturellement ce doute moi
j'avoue que s'il y avait pas eu
l'article 40 d'ailleurs sans doute que
j'aurais déposé un amendement plutôt sur
une prime que sur une exonération ceci
dit j'ai été sensible aux arguments du
du rapporteur sur les partenaires
sociaux et la négociation raison pour
laquelle je retire mes deux sous
amendements et je pense que on fait un
pari parce que si on si on augmente pas
la quantité de travail et la quantité
des seniors au travail bien évidemment
alors je suis sensible à l'argument de
Madame Rossignol et au risque
d'affaiblir le financement de la branche
famille mais on fait un pari et ce pari
nous devons le faire d'augmenter le taux
de travail de décennies pour financer
notre système de retraite par
répartition je pense d'ailleurs et c'est
la raison pour laquelle je retire ces
deux sous amendements
ils nous devons chaque fois que nous le
pouvons laisser le plus de l'attitude
possible à la négociation des
partenaires sociaux c'est l'état
d'esprit qui est celui de notre groupe
si nous voulons aussi redonner du grain
à moudre et faire en sorte qu'on ait un
pari tarisme refondé et rénové et ce
sera une dépression de de la loi travail
à venir je vous remercie merci Monsieur
Breuillet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur du
ministre chers collègues j'ai commencé
par un point d'accord avec ce que vient
de dire monsieur Hainaut je pense
qu'effectivement il s'agit d'un chantier
qui devrait être ouvert avec les
partenaires sociaux dans la négociation
interprofessionnelle avant de venir en
débat parmi nous bien sûr il y a un
énorme problème du travail des seniors
nous l'avons d'ailleurs évoqué
longuement hier à propos de l'index pour
lequel il y a un refus de toute mesure
contraignante
ce chantier devrait donc être ouvert
avec les partenaires sociaux et je veux
dire un point d'accord avec le ministre
Attal aussi sur les critiques qu'il fait
du dispositif un point d'accord
notamment lorsqu'il critique les mesures
de bornes
mais j'ai espéré qu'il y avait pas de à
cet état des mesures de bornes alors
c'est moi qui est qui est
j'avais mal compris monsieur le ministre
j'ai pensé qu'il pouvait y avoir un
sous-entendu donc c'était juste les
mesures d'âge pardon mais effectivement
il peut y avoir un effet de bornes ou de
seuil avec une mesure comme celle-là et
notamment qui impacterait des gens âgés
de 58 59 ans dans la question de l'accès
à l'emploi et tout aussi importantes et
puis enfin dernière remarque on parle
toujours d'exonération et ensuite on
parle toujours des déficits de
l'ensemble des caisses publiques donc
comme l'a évoqué un collègue et je
m'excuse de ne pas le citer avant moi je
suggère effectivement qu'on diminue pour
inciter les entreprises embauchées
peut-être dans le cadre de l'index qu'on
diminue les très nombreuses exonérations
qui leur sont accordés à celles qui ne
respectent pas le taux d'emploi des
seniors ou et qu'on les maintiennent à
celles qui embauche en tous les cas
qu'on
souligne l'intérêt de maintenir ses
exonérations uniquement pour ceux qui
embauchent réellement ou qui servent des
enjeux climatiques
monsieur le Président Retailleau
moi je considère que
l'amendement de René Paul Savary que
nous allons voter évidemment
révèle un enjeu qui est un des plus
grand de cette réforme parce que à quoi
servirait-il d'augmenter de reculer
l'âge légal de départ si on ne fait rien
sur l'emploi des seniors vous savez
parfaitement que le taux de chômage et
un certain nombre de ces natrices et de
sénateurs de l'opposition l'ont répété
hier touche tout particulièrement les
seniors et nous nous contentons pas de
ce que nous dit le gouvernement le
gouvernement dit mais nous on a un outil
extraordinaire c'est l'index l'index est
une statistique certes il y aura l'effet
diamondshine en bon vendéen pardon mais
ça n'est pas suffisant nous voulons
trouver un autre outil et c'est ce qu'a
fait la commission la commission nous a
dit on peut peut-être trouver à travers
ce nouveau contrat qui va s'adresser à
des seniors un outil qui permettra de
lutter contre le chômage des seniors
vous faites plusieurs reproches je vais
y répondre René Paul Savary a répondu au
reproches de la négociation avec les
partenaires sociaux il y a trois
reproches essentiellement vous dites un
effet d'Aubade oui il y aurait eu un
effet d'aubaine si le contrat
s'adressait au plus de 60 ans qui sont
déjà dans l'entreprise non là ça ne sera
pas le cas ce sera des gens qu'on va
sortir du chômage et qui vont rentrer
sur le marché du travail première chose
et vous savez parfaitement parfaitement
qu'on embauche très très peu en France
après 60 ans donc il y a pas d'effet
d'Aubagne il y a pas d'effet d'auben
deuxième reproche que vous faites sur le
coup nous contestons formellement nous
contestons formellement le coût du
gouvernement nous le contestons parce
que le gouvernement
ne regarde qu'une ligne la ligne de la
dépense mais il s'agit d'activer en
réalité des dépenses chômage
d'indemnisation et il s'agit de faire en
sorte que des gens qui bénéficient
bénéficier parce qu'ils ont un emploi
des économies sont chiffrés ce à quoi
revient par exemple 100 000 seniors qui
ont réintègre sur le marché du travail
c'est près d'un milliard donc vous voyez
que c'est une mesure qui à notre sens ne
coûtera pas mais au contraire rapportera
et troisième élément troisième reproche
que vous avez fait ça va assécher la
branche famille non puisque pour
l'instant ils sont au chômage il y a pas
de cotisation famille donc il s'agit
encore une fois et c'est l'esprit
d'ailleurs de la réforme de réactiver et
de faire en sorte le taux d'activités
madame le héros
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président excusez-moi
vous proposez d'instaurer un nouveau
type de contrat de travail afin de
favoriser l'emploi d'un seigneur mais la
question n'est pas de créer un nouveau
CDI mais que les entreprises gardent
leur salarié de 55 ans et plus votre
proposition risque de mettre en
concurrence des seniors avec les jeunes
sur le seul critère du coup du travail
sachant que les jeunes aussi ont du mal
à s'insérer vous exonérer les
entreprises de cotisation familiales
donc vous ponctionnez ça vient d'être
dit les caisses d'allocations familiales
la protection sociale de nos familles or
nous savons que cette politique
familiale a besoin de moyens pour mettre
en place un vrai service public de la
petite enfance il nous manque des places
en crèche nous avons besoin de moyens
pour financer les congés pour l'égalité
femme homme soit une soit en réalité
tout simplement le l'égalité
professionnelle qui passe aussi par une
égalité des droits des deux parents à
accompagner l'arrivée de l'enfant dans
le foyer
nous avons besoin de cotisations pour
compenser les congés de maternité alors
que les femmes pour que les femmes et
les mêmes droits au départ à la retraite
d'ailleurs monsieur le ministre du socle
avec le la première ministre vous
considériez initialement que les
exonérations de cotisation n'était pas
le meilleur moyen pour agir sur l'emploi
des seniors alors quels sont les
éléments qui vous ont fait changer
d'avis il serait intéressant pour nous
de les connaître pour notre part nous ne
changions pas d'avis le meilleur moyen
de maintenir les seigneurs en emploi
jusque 62 ans et de ne pas changer l'âge
légal de départ nous savons déjà que un
salarié sur deux n'est pas un emploi sur
la tranche d'âge des 50-64 ans de 55 ans
merci Madame Ferré
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voulais
revenir sur la question du véhicule
législatif vous allez me dire encore et
toujours oui encore et toujours parce
que à nouveau avec cette article
additionnel et bien on voit que le
véhicule législatif que le gouvernement
a choisi n'est pas le bon vous avez dit
je vais revenir sur les propos de
Monsieur le rapporteur il aurait été
plus judicieux de proposer une
exonération de cotisation chômage dans
la mesure où l'embauche de seigneur
réduit le chômage oui mais problème nous
sommes dans une loi de finances
rectificative et l'assurance chômage
étant dehors de ce cadre alors oui ce
véhicule législatif n'est décidément pas
le bon s'agissant des exonérations et la
proposition qui est faite d'exonérer au
travers de ce CDI comme ma collègue je
m'interroge CDI c'est qu'on n'est pas de
fin quand on ne connaît pas la fin là on
la connaît cette date de fin puisque
c'est la date de départ en retraite de
la personne qui serait recruter donc
plutôt de ce CDD monsieur le ministre
vous vous je vous dis les exonérations
de cotisations ne sont pas le meilleur
moyen pour développer l'emploi des
seigneurs des seniors pour moi pardon
pour moi ce n'est pas le meilleur moyen
c'est ça n'est pas le moyen pour
développer l'emploi des seniors c'est
effectivement monsieur atteint le
ministre que vous avez dit que le coût
de cet amendement serait de 800 millions
d'euros c'est pas rien c'est pas rien
tout comme si on additionne et si on
regarde l'ensemble du coup ou l'ensemble
des exonérations employeurs qui sont de
l'ordre de 80 milliards d'euros alors
cessons de faire des propositions qui
pourraient convenir plutôt et je le dis
moi aussi
sans complexe et en assumant
complètement ce que je dis qui sont de
véritables cadeaux aux entreprises ce
sont d'être dans cette volonté d'aider
les entreprises et non pas celles et
ceux qui sont sans emploi parce que
aussi le risque est réel de mettre en
concurrence les seniors et les jeunes
avec ce seul critère du coût du travail
madame la Présidente Laurence Rossignol
merci monsieur le Président je n'imagine
pas que cet amendement puisse être autre
chose qu'un amendement d'appel et je
voudrais faire quelques remarques
d'abord au ministre qui nous dit j'ai
pas de tabou sur les exonérations
sociales
oui un peu quand même vous en avez
monsieur le ministre parce que 75
milliards annuels d'exonération de
charges sociales et un discours
permanent sur les déficits publics mais
jamais aucun lien n'est fait entre le
montant le volume des exonérations de
charge sociale et le montant des
déficits publics pour autant il y en a
un et celui-là il est toujours dans le
tabou puisque vous n'en parlez pas
deuxième remarque c'est que
vous monsieur Savary et je pense que
vous êtes sincère quand vous le dites
vous renvoyez à la négocié à la
consultation des partenaires sociaux
permettant de vous dire que en ce moment
sur la consultation des partenaires
sociaux à l'initiative de ce
gouvernement on est pour le moins
prudent sur la nature de cette
concertation et ce que les partenaires
sociaux pourraient obtenir comme
garantie dans une négociation avec le
gouvernement qui a décidé de ne plus de
s'émanciper de la vie des partenaires
sociaux en matière de politique sociale
parce que dans cet amendement moi j'ai
pas tout compris mais peut-être que
peut-être j'ai pas été assez comment
dire rigoureuse ou attentive vous avez
dit tout à l'heure que l'employeur
s'engage à garder le salarié nonobstant
l'ensemble de toutes les autres règles
du Code du travail concernant le
licenciement par exemple je n'imagine
pas qu'il s'agisse d'un engagement qui
émancie et qui protège le travailleur
dans toutes les circonstances on
commence à s'articuler avec le
licenciement habituel pour faute pour
licenciement économique plan social à ce
moment là il y a plus d'engagement donc
là on a besoin quand même je crois de
retravailler un peu et puis tout à
l'heure le président Retailleau nous a
dit que à la fois que il voyait pas bien
enfin qu'il y avait un lien entre cet
amendement et le recul d'âge et puis
notre collègue Olivier Hainaut a dit que
c'était un pari alors moi j'aime bien
que les paris soit équitables il y a ça
c'est un pari mais le recul d'âge dans
l'esprit du gouvernement c'est pas un
pari c'est un coup près qui va qui
s'appliquerait de la loi merci Monsieur
fichier
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre c'est juste une précision
parce que Corinne Ferrer en a fait état
tout à l'heure on parle de CDI mais en
fait c'est un CDD dont il s'agit d'un
CDD de 4 ans puisqu'il sera signé à
l'âge de 60 ans et à 64 ans c'est
terminé il y a donc une sorte de CDD
vieux ou de contrats de dernière
embauche en fait en plus on ne peut pas
comprendre le fait que ça s'arrête à 64
ans puisque si les personnes souhaitent
aller jusqu'à 70 ans ce n'est que mieux
puisque c'est même personne pendant ce
temps-là démarreront pas aux caisses de
retraite donc autant d'économie de fait
je crois que du coup ça vaut le coup d'y
réfléchir je vous remercie et Madame
meunier
c'est le Président Monsieur les
ministres chers collègues tout d'abord
moi je voudrais dire que je me réjouis
de la tonalité de nos propos et de la
belle qualité des débats ce matin ça
augure je pense d'une belle semaine à
venir
monsieur Savary le rapporteur ça varie
vous avez dit vous-même que par cet
amendement qui n'est qu'un outil nouveau
c'est un site que vous l'avez qualifié
certes mais c'est un outil au service
d'une mécanique que nous ne voulons pas
donc désolé mais ne je ne voterai pas
votre amendement monsieur le ministre
Attal vous avez dit que c'était un
risque mais c'est l'ensemble du projet
de loi qui est un risque un risque pour
les personnes qui sont concernées les
plus modestes celles qui ont travaillé
dans des métiers les plus difficiles et
qui verront de fait deux ans
supplémentaires de cotisations avant de
partir à la retraite et puis vous dites
que vous n'avez pas de tabous ça a été
souligné tout à l'heure des tabous
concernant les exonérations et ça je
veux bien vous croire par contre vous
avez des tabous concernant les recettes
et les possibilités de recettes
nouvelles nous vous en avons fait de ce
côté de l'hémicycle et vous persistez à
ne pas les entendre la taxation sur les
supers profits les contributions sur les
eaux salaires et les grosses fortunes et
toutes celles que nous avons pu aussi
décliner que déclinerons tout au long de
ce débat merci merci Monsieur vanner
merci monsieur le Président
moi je rejoins tout à fait ce que disait
tout à l'heure le Président retaillod si
on ne fait rien pour inciter à
l'embauche des seniors on passe à côté
d'un point essentiel c'est très fort
j'ai auditionné avec le groupe le
professeur Lorenzi président du Cercle
des économistes qui a calculé que si en
France nous rattrapions tout simplement
le déficit dans l'emploi des seniors
rappelle que ces 10 points de déficit
par rapport à la moyenne de l'OCDE ça
rapporterait 13 milliards
pour notre système de retraite 13
milliards
je crois que les chiffres parlent
d'eux-mêmes
d'ailleurs je crois que sur le ministre
dans vos
papiers notamment ceux qui nous ont été
donnés lorsque nous avions fait le bilan
d'étape vous parliez de pour cent mille
emplois créés le senior un milliard de
recettes supplémentaires vous pouvez le
confirmer j'ai imagine aisément je les
élus ce sont des chiffres qui nous
permettent d'envisager et je rejoins
tout à fait la position que
défendait tout à l'heure Olivier Hainaut
plutôt une prime à l'embauche que des
exonérations
les exonérations on le sait tous les
PLFSS on se plaint des exonérations et
l'État est obligé de compenser les
exonérations depuis le vote de la loi
organique n'est-ce pas monsieur ministre
donc je crois que le plus simple ce
serait de mettre une prime à l'embauche
quant à un emploi rapporte enfin 100000
emplois rapportent un milliard on sait
qu'on peut libérer effectivement
quelques centaines de millions pour
pouvoir permettre à des seniors de
retrouver effectivement la dignité du
travail merci
[Applaudissements]
et ensuite ce sera le président Gontard
merci Monsieur la Président Monsieur les
ministres je crois que à travers les
discussions que nous avons nous
constatons très bien qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'une proposition de loi de gauche plus
on avance plus on se rend compte que
cette proposition est que les
différentes propositions qui sont faits
également notamment celles qui a été
faite par notre rapporteur et bien ne
correspondent pas il faudrait une vraie
loi pour parler de la retraite pour
parler du travail des jeunes des jeunes
et pour parler des seniors parce que là
on est dans la confusion on est dans le
bricolage et ce n'est pas le bon
véhicule pour aller en Guadeloupe je
prends l'avion je ne vais pas prendre
une trottinette donc bien on est dans un
cas de figure qui serait similaire donc
je crois aujourd'hui que nous devons
être sérieux nous devons travailler dans
l'intérêt premier des seniors et là la
façon d'aborder les choses dans
l'appréhender s'apparente à une façon de
les maltraités les la météo pour fille
des entreprises parce que les éléments
qui sont évoqués chacun entendu mais
c'est pas normal ce n'est pas normal
parler de la broche family moi je veux
bien parce qu'il y a beaucoup à faire et
ma collègue vient de discuter de
proposer un certain nombre de pistes
nous ne pouvons pas faire n'importe quoi
nous ne devons pas faire n'importe quoi
dans mon territoire la question des
jeunes se pose beaucoup plus que des
seigneurs mais les seigneurs aussi donc
nous devons mettre en oeuvre tout ce
qu'il faut tous les moyens pour une
vraie loi de retraite et ne pas faire
n'importe quoi pour les seniors les
maltraités c'est maltraités les enfants
c'est maltraiter les plus jeunes c'est
maltraiter la société merci
président comptable
monsieur Kerrouche se prépare oui merci
merci monsieur le Président moi très
rapidement je voulais juste lever
peut-être une petite incohérence parce
que j'ai écouté le président Retailleau
tout à l'heure et
puis j'ai regardé ce qu'il avait pu dire
et dans une belle envolée je crois que
c'était hier sur les bienfaits du recul
de l'âge et il nous disait le recul de
l'âge procure un autre avantage nous
allons automatiquement mécaniquement
augmenter le temps d'emploi des seniors
et ainsi mettre plus de travail dans la
machine et donc je m'étonne un petit peu
que du coup aujourd'hui on nous explique
bah que non justement mécaniquement
automatiquement ça ne fonctionnera pas
mais qu'il faut un dispositif un autre
dispositif peut-être de l'huile du coup
dans la machine pour pouvoir employer
ces seniors donc c'est vrai que là je
vois une petite une petite incohérence
que j'aimerais bien lever parce que ça
me paraît important d'ailleurs tarlin un
de vos collègues nous ont dit si on ne
fait rien on aura tout faux donc voilà
j'aimerais essayer de
comprendre parce que c'est vrai que si
justement ce bien fait de l'âge de recul
à la retraite ces fameux deux ans vont
nous permettre mécaniquement il me
semble que ce dispositif pour le coup ne
sert à rien à moins que ça soit
simplement un faux CDI et simplement une
voie de garage
merci merci monsieur le Président sur le
dispositif qui nous est proposé on ne
peut que contester son existence parce
que le problème c'est sa finalité qu'on
a du mal à percevoir c'est quoi la vraie
finalité de ce contrat qui est un
contrat dont on imagine mal la portée
dans le temps avec toutes les limites
qui ont été qui ont été imposées et puis
on a entendu monsieur le ministre
monsieur Attal nous dire que cette
disposition aurait un effet particulier
puisqu'elle coûte elle coûterait 800
millions d'euros mais je suis un peu
surpris par la dualité du discours parce
que quand il s'agit de supprimer la taxe
d'habitation à peu près 26 milliards
d'euros dont 8 milliards pour les 20%
les les plus les plus aisés quand on
supprime la CVAE là
l'exécutif fait des paris et on n'a pas
du tout de vision sur ce qui vont être
ou ce qui pourrait être les conséquences
c'est des paris par contre quand il est
question d'augmenter même de manière
modérée les recettes sociales pour
financer la protection sociale là ce
n'est plus possible d'en parler il y a
tout un ensemble de solutions qui
existent et que nous vous proposons
régulièrement comme l'augmentation du
taux d'emploi des seniors comme
l'égalité homme femme comme simplement
comme l'a montré Tobin Piketty
l'augmentation de 2% de la CSG sur les
hauts patrimoine qui viendrait compenser
l'ensemble des besoins du système de
retraite la vraie question c'est
pourquoi d'un côté vous êtes
relativement timoré et pourquoi de
l'autre il faudrait alors vous faire
confiance
la vos gel
oui merci monsieur le Président je
voulais aller dans le sens du de mon
collègue Guillaume Gontard pour dire que
nous trouvons ici dans une situation un
peu un peu curieuse on a d'un côté dans
ce côté-là de l'hémicycle des collègues
qui nous disent cette réforme est
nécessaire et elle est très utile
notamment pour l'emploi des seniors
parce automatiquement en augmentant
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite on
va augmenter le nombre de seniors en
emploi et en même temps on nous dit si
on crée part un CDI senior ou peu
importe comment il s'appelle exactement
on passe à côté de l'élément essentiel
de cette réforme qui est absent
aujourd'hui du projet de loi donc déjà
est-ce qu'on pourrait peut-être se
mettre d'accord entre nous sur le fait
de dire que le recul de l'âge de départ
à la retraite ne crée pas d'emploi chez
les seniors puisque les républicains ont
eux-mêmes déposé un amendement pour
réparer ce qu'ils ont ce qu'il décrivait
comme pourtant étant déjà dans la
réforme ça c'est une première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que bon moi j'avais
pas ces chiffres en tête mais je les
crois bien volontiers notre collègue
vient de nous dire si on avait si on
corrigé l'écart de d'emploi des seniors
en France par rapport à la moyenne de
l'UE on aurait 13 milliards dans les
caisses c'est à dire en gros bien ce que
ce qu'on cherche c'est de l'ordre de 13
milliards qu'on cherche et on a un
dispositif qu'on nous propose qui
consiste à baisser des cotisations donc
à appauvrir les caisses de la Sécurité
sociale donc on marche sur la tête d'un
côté on nous dit cette réforme va
permettre d'augmenter l'emploi des
seniors mais comme elle ne le fait pas
on a besoin d'un outil qui va nous
permettre que l'emploi des seniors donne
moins dans les caisses de la Sécurité
sociale dont nous avons besoin pour
financer les retraites je veux dire à un
moment donné il y a un aspect de pure
cohérence intellectuelle qui m'échappe
totalement
madame line
[Musique]
on voit bien que cette proposition
d'une part fait le constat du fait que
ça va aggraver la situation des seniors
certes il y aura quelques créations de
prolongement mais le gros du paquet va
rester ni emploi ni
retraite et comme d'habitude la seule
idée qui vient à droite c'est que j'en
ai des cotisations sociales ça fait des
lustres
que vous avez des contrats de ceci
premier embauche dernier machin là ça va
être dernier embauche et l'efficacité je
m'excuse de dire c'est la bulle par
contre l'assèchement des comptes de la
protection sociale ça c'est du sérieux
alors
parlons des cotisations
s'il y avait l'égalité salariale femme
qui est peut-être quand même plus facile
à atteindre que de faire travailler des
gens qui pour une part sont dans des
situations très difficiles pour pouvoir
travailler on aurait déjà fait la moitié
de vos 13 milliards là on en serait à 6
ou 7
deuxièmement ça fait des années des
années qu'on explique que les
exonérations de cotisations sociales si
elles sont elles peuvent être
pertinentes elles ne le peuvent être
qu'à deux conditions la première c'est
qu'elle soit ciblée vers des activités
par exemple pour accompagner la
réindustrialisation l'évolution de la
transition et une écologique etc et si
elles sont conditionnées c'est à dire
s'il y a des garanties au lieu de créer
le énième
la énième cotisation allégée
exiger que pour avoir l’allègement
l'équivalent c'est du du contrat du
les allégements Hollande contrat bon
bref
c'est voilà merci la contrepartie de
l'équivalent ici soit conditionné un
accord ou à des engagements concernant
toute une série de critères dont
l'augmentation de la part des seniors là
vous ne faites pas dépenses
supplémentaires vous ciblez merci alors
je vais maintenant donner la parole il
n'y a plus bande d'explication de vote à
Madame la rapporteur général
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres chers collègues j'ai entendu
parler de concurrence entre les jeunes
et les vieux alors là c'est quelque
chose que que j'ai du mal à entendre
parce que je crois que alors je suis
peut-être idéaliste mais en réalité je
crois à l'utilité de chacun dans la
société il y a pas de mise en
concurrence de telles catégories
vis-à-vis de tel autre je pense qu'on a
dans ce pays parfois penser à des
politiques spécifiques pour les jeunes
on a moins pensé aux politiques
spécifiques pour les seniors c'est
dommage il y a quand même un territoire
le Val-de-Marne qui a pensé et nous
avons auditionné d'ailleurs les acteurs
de ce dispositif qui s'appelle label
plus 45 et c'était très intéressant de
les entendre parce que en réalité on
pourrait déployer ce type de dispositif
un petit peu partout c'est à dire
sensibiliser l'entreprise sensibilité la
population parce que comme je le disais
hier c'est notre société qui doit
changer de mentalité vis-à-vis de nos
aînés les aînés ont des choses à
transmettre les aînés ont des choses à
dire aux jeunes alors que on a de plus
en plus de d'apprentis dans notre dans
nos territoires on devrait justement
capitaliser si c'est un terme qui ne
vous plaît pas moi je pense qu'on peut
capitaliser sur le savoir des anciens et
donc un contrat tel que il est proposé
est aussi sur cette dimension là cette
idéale là de transmettre et de et de
permettre à nos seniors et bien
d'apporter aux jeunes une sorte de
tutorat de mantorat qui est utile alors
c'est vrai que ce contrat est sans doute
pas bien écrit et qui qu'il faut y
repenser mais il y a effectivement une
loi de travail qui qui arrive donc on
pourra le travailler ensemble si je puis
dire mais je voudrais reparler aussi de
l'index Seigneur parce que moi il me
semble que dans cette index Seigneur il
faudra penser dans la loi travail à y
mettre un bonus on
sans allonger les débats mais elle me
semble
indispensable non je ne suis pas
asservie aux Medef à tel point que
j'accepte bien volontiers l'indicateur
je crois pas que ce soit le Medef qui
réclame l'indicateur mais permettez-moi
de vous dire que
j'ai des relations toujours respectueuse
avec les différents partenaires sociaux
que ce soit le Medef FO j'ai eu
l'occasion de rencontrer auditionné son
secrétaire général je rencontrais
régulièrement madame pizza puisqu'elle
est présidente de l'argile Carco et puis
d'autres dans le cadre du corps et
Monique Lubin c'est bien les discussions
qu'on peut avoir au niveau du corps on
évite effectivement de parler ce qu'il
fâche sinon on en sortirait pas une fois
qu'on a dit ça on peut parler d'autre
chose et notamment de l'employé habilité
des seniors et c'est comme ça que à
force de discussion est venue cette idée
pas inventé si vous voulez je voulais
remettre un petit peu
ça vous le dire en toute en toute
s'intéresserité donc indépendant de tout
cela vous voyez vous j'ai pas
effectivement écouté toutes les
propositions de tout j'en ai choisi
quelques-unes deuxièmement
il a été
dit à travers une intervention que il
fallait plutôt que s'occuper des seniors
au chômage qu'il fallait mieux s'occuper
des seniors en emploi oui aussi les
seigneurs en emploi c'est pour ça que
notamment vous êtes les premiers à
dénoncer ce qu'on dénoncer aussi qu'il
faut prendre des mesures pour les maires
de famille et les mesures des mers de
famille qu'on va vous proposer c'est
effectivement parce que elle reste en
emploi un peu plus longtemps peut-être
avec l'effet de décalage de l'âge mais
surtout avec l'effet de la réforme
Touraine
de faire en sorte de vouloir
particulièrement mettre les seniors au
travail c'est l'application de la
réforme Touraine on travaille 43 ans
quand vous voyez vous avez commencé à 20
ans vous travaillez 43 ans mais quand
vous avez commencé à travailler à 22 ans
un vous travaillez jusque Canac jusque
65 ans c'est la réforme Touraine l'effet
d'âge effectivement effectivement il
peut avoir aussi un effet mais je
voudrais qu'on soit clair entre nous
très clair entre nous
c'est pas 43 ans plus deux ans du
au travail supplémentaire soit disant de
soit 62 à 64 non non c'est l'ajustement
des bornes et effectivement de par la
réforme Touraine certains seront ou
certaines seront amenés à travailler
plus longtemps et d'autres par les faits
de l'âge légal seront à travailler
quelques mois également plus longtemps
peut-être
années pour certaines générations mais
c'est pas deux ans de plus pour tout le
monde arrêtez de vendre un argument qui
est faux parce qu'effectivement ça
contribue à mettre les gens dans la rue
mais si on leur explique bien la
différence elle est quand même
importante
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc je ne suis pas le bourreau
des seniors que vous prétendez que je
sois ensuite effectivement il y a eu il
y a eu des propositions de la belle
Jean-Marie un garçon sage Jean-Marie
connais bien le dispositif il connaît
bien les syndicats et il est pas servi
non plus un syndicat mais ne connaît
bien ben écoutez moi je partage aussi ça
un index à pénalise un label ça valorise
bon on peut peut-être trouver un
équilibre entre les deux
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président très
rapidement je veux pas contribuer à
allonger les débats je pense qu'on a été
suffisamment éclairé mais je voudrais
répondre à quelques points qui ont été
évoqués qui peuvent je pense être utile
dans les choix que les uns et les autres
feront au moment du vote si l'amendement
n'est pas retiré d'abord pour répondre à
monsieur vandlerenberg je vous rejoins
totalement
sur la question du taux d'emploi si on
avait le même taux d'emploi en France
que nos voisins allemands moi j'aurais
pas de travail j'en aurai beaucoup moins
pour équilibrer les comptes puisque les
recettes supplémentaires induite par 10
points de taux d'emploi en plus nous
permettrait d'équilibrer ou en tout cas
d'équilibrer beaucoup mieux nos budgets
donc la question c'est comment est-ce
qu'on améliore le taux d'emploi
améliorer le taux d'emploi ça veut dire
travailler sur les jeunes et c'est donc
tout ce qu'on a fait notamment sur
l'apprentissage ce qu'on doit faire sur
la réforme du lycée professionnel qui
aujourd'hui objectivement ne permet pas
d'insérer véritablement les jeunes dans
l'emploi et donc c'est une réforme qui
est particulièrement importante et deux
sur les seniors et donc oui on doit
s'interroger collectivement sur les
mesures les plus efficaces pour
améliorer le taux d'emploi des seniors
et c'est vrai et je réponds à Madame
Vogel notamment c'est vrai que la
réforme de 2010 a permis une
amélioration du taux d'emploi des
seniors de 15 points depuis 2010 toutes
les études qui ont été réalisées le
disent et il y a pas eu besoin de
contrats spécifiques après la réforme
Fillon de 2010 pour améliorer de 15
points le taux d'emploi des seniors mais
évidemment qu'on doit penser à des
mesures supplémentaires il y a l'index
il peut y en avoir d'autres moi j'ai
entendu le rapporteur général comme
Monsieur vandlerenberg dire que ce
dispositif de CDI senior était peut-être
pas le mieux abouti donc moi je
proposerai volontiers de retirer cet
amendement et qu'on retravaille les
choses peut-être en vue de la loi
travail ou du prochain PLFSS mais encore
une fois prendre une mesure qui
coûterait 800 millions d'euros à la
branche famille sans qu'on ait de
garantie sur son efficacité vous avez
parlé de Paris mais je suis pas
totalement convaincu et pour répondre à
Monsieur Retailleau l'effet d'aubaine ça
serait si toutes les entreprises qui ont
actuellement un contrat avec un senior
de plus de 60 ans le transformer en CDI
senior là ça serait 2 milliards 300
millions donc c'est pas ça dont je parle
quand je parle des 800 millions d'euros
le coût de 800 millions d'euros c'est le
coût pour les seniors qui aujourd'hui
rentrent dans un contrat après 60 ans
vous en avez 100 000 à peu près chaque
année qui sont recrutés on imagine assez
bien qu'un chef d'entreprise qui recrute
un seigneur qui a plus de 60 ans il a le
choix entre le CDI classique sans
allègement de cotisation sur la branche
famille et le CDI senior où il a 5
points de cotisation en moins sur
les cotisations familles il va plutôt
choisir le CDI senior donc d'ores et
déjà pour les seniors qui sont
aujourd'hui recrutés sans disposer sans
qui ai besoin dispositif supplémentaires
ça coûte 800 millions d'euros donc
peut-être qu'il y en aura d'autres qui
le seront à ce moment-là en plus mais
enfin il en faudrait beaucoup pour que
ça compense les faits avant de conclure
je veux juste revenir sur la question
des allègements et des exonérations de
cotisation ça a été abordé et j'ai
entendu parler notamment monsieur
kerouge de dualité dans le discours etc
il y a eu depuis 20 ans deux grandes
étapes d'allègement de cotisation pour
les entreprises
la première de ces deux grandes étapes
depuis 20 ans c'est le PLFSS 2014
présenté à l'époque de François Hollande
avec notamment les allègements et les
exonérations maladie et familles pour 25
milliards d'euros 25 milliards d'euros
dans le PLFSS 2014 je suis allé regarder
j'ai demandé à mon équipe de Me
ressortir le scrutin public de l'époque
l'intégralité du groupe socialiste à
l'époque avait voté la mesure
d'exonération de 25 milliards d'euros de
cotisations maladie et famille à
l'exception de trois sénateurs je décide
quand même madame linmann qui à l'époque
n'avait pas souhaité le voter et
Monsieur Godefroy et monsieur daudini
qui ne sont ne siège plus mais le groupe
socialiste à l'époque avait voté 25
milliards d'euros de baisse de
cotisations pour les entreprises ensuite
la deuxième étape c'est la
transformation du cice en baisse de
cotisation 2019 Emmanuel Macron
président de la République ce qui est
intéressant de regarder c'est qu'entre
avant la transformation du cice en
baisse de cotisation et aujourd'hui
on perçoit aujourd'hui 21 milliards de
recettes en plus pour la sécurité
sociale parce que comme on a baissé les
cotisations il y a plus d'embauches un
million 500000 de plus et donc on
perçoit aujourd'hui plus de recettes
puisqu'il y a plus de personnes qui
travaillent pour la sécurité sociale
donc oui alléger les cotisations a
permis d'élargir le nombre de
recrutement et donc d'avoir des recettes
supplémentaires pour la sécu donc pour
ces raisons-là c'est pour ça que je dis
j'ai pas de tabou sur la question des
baisses de cotisations merci Monsieur
Louise la majorité de droite et du
centre du Sénat donc voté en faveur de
la création d'un CDI senior qui incite à
les entreprises à embaucher des salariés
de plus de 60 ans le gouvernement s'est
montré défavorable à ce dispositif qu'il
juge trop coûteux pour les finances de
la sécurité sociale et de son côté la
gauche inattoriale a dénoncé
l’inefficacité des exonérations de
cotisations sociales pour favoriser
l'emploi notez qu'aujourd'hui le Sénat
va examiner l'article 7 de cette réforme
des retraites un article qui reporte
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite à 64
ans et et vous pourrez suivre ces débats
en direct sur Public Sénat en fin
d'après-midi en soirée et pendant toute
la nuit voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi
continuer à suivre l'examen de cette
réforme des retraites au Sénat sur
Public Sénat et également sur public
sénat.fr je vous souhaite une très bonne
journée sur Public Sénat
[Musique]